[Music]
[Applause]
we bring in mike florio the popular
co-host of pro football talk live you
can see that preceding our show on
peacock with chris sims and his new book
playmakers must read it's coming out
march 15th could be purchased online
wherever books are sold
who's going to be upset by this book
mike when it comes out
everybody yeah i don't know look i it
was funny because my wife was reading a
draft of it last summer and when she
finished it she said this is really
going to piss a lot of people off
and and i said it's nothing that i
haven't said or written before it's just
all collected in one spot so
anybody has a problem with it it's their
problem because it's my honest
assessment of the way the nfl operates
and the nfl is the greatest product from
a sports standpoint
in the country if not on the planet
because no matter what it does by way of
making missteps unforced errors
controversies scandals things that have
been mishandled from a business
standpoint
still making more money than anything
else still gathering a live audience
like nothing else it almost has to try
to impede its progress and even if it
tries it's still going to continue to
grow and grow and grow dan but i
remember when mark cuban came out and
said you know that the nfl's got to be
careful uh you know when you're adding
thursday night football and uh i think
it was talking about uh hogs get fat and
get slaughtered
can you see an over saturation at any
point with the nfl
i remember that well pigs could get fat
hogs get slaughtered and for a while i
was concerned about that but i just
think our appetite for football
has not yet reached the point where
anyone would say okay that's enough
we always want more no matter how much
more we get we want more
the transition to thursday was a little
clunky
and there were concerns about it from a
health standpoint and those are real
concerns and there were players who
complained about it richard sherman
called it a poop fest one of my all-time
favorite quotes from any player but you
know what the nfl just keeps its head
down keeps going and now thursday night
is baked in to the schedule we would be
feeling as if something's off if we
didn't have thursday night football and
you just have to wonder as the season
continues to grow and i think 18 games
is just a matter of time will they look
for other windows tuesday night
wednesday night what else will they do
because dan with legalized gambling is
going to drive this bus
they're going to look for ways to have
more one game at a time that millions
can watch
and bet on not just
the bigger wagers
one play at a time the technology that
will beam the games into our houses so
as we're watching it it's exactly what's
happening
at the stadium we get 40 seconds between
plays to make our next bet it basically
becomes a casino that invades your home
whenever there's a game on so i think
they're going to expand the season and
they're going gonna spread out the
windows so people can tune in for more
of these games so those opportunities
for people to bet
will be maximized could you see us
exporting the super bowl in the next
decade
i'd be stunned if it happens i think
they like to talk about it from time to
time i think it's part of the tease
that the nfl engages in with the uk just
to get them thinking well maybe someday
we'll have the super bowl i mean how can
you how can you play the super bowl at
11 30 p.m
local time kickoff how could you do that
that's what they would have to do if
they're going to play a super bowl in
london at some point now to the average
american fan it doesn't matter it looks
the same on the tv all the london games
look the same it's no big deal 99 of the
fans or more aren't going to ever go to
a super bowl in their lifetime they're
watching it on tv it doesn't matter
where it's played but i think
i think the the allure of that helps
grow the sport internationally and
before you get to a point where super
bowl is played
in a place like london you'd have to
have a team there and i i think that
continues to be this vague promise
that's on the table and i think there
would be two teams they got two nfl
stadiums and i think if there was ever
one team in london there'd be two teams
in london
all right let me get to the poll
question today seton would you give uh
mike florio the wording on our poll
question today yesterday's letter from
kyler murray's agent was best four the
cardinals or kyler
is there a c neither
i
i mean i i don't think it really helps
anybody but it's how about this the rest
of us because it allows the rest up to
understand what's really going on here
these vague reports we've seen in recent
weeks
kyler murray taking the team off of his
social media platforms the chris
mortenson report from super bowl sunday
about kyler being self-centered immature
and finger-pointing
here's the problem dan
it used to be if you were a quarterback
who did well enough to earn a second
contract the default was you became
the next highest paid player in league
history and it would go up about a half
million per year for each guy and that
went on for six seven eight guys
in the past two or three years that's
changed you've got a 15 million dollar
per year spread from number one down to
number 10. so yeah the cardinals want to
sign the guy
but what do they want to pay him they
want to pay closer to 30 i believe than
45 and his agent eric burkhart who also
represents cliff kingsbury which makes
it even more awkward for the team
burkhart's going to want closer to 45 if
not more
and and one of the points burkhart made
recently in response to the notion that
aaron rodgers deserves 50 million if not
more when you have announcers making 20
million a year when pat mcafee is
getting 30 million a year from fanduel
there's money in the system to support
more for the guys who are actually
playing the game and i think that's
where we're going to see this go and
murray's going to be the first test case
of how much burkhardt tries to get and
how much the cardinals are willing to
pay
i haven't heard anything about lamar
jackson lamar jackson is far more worthy
of an extension than kyler murray is
well here's the problem lamar jackson
decided for whatever reason and this is
an individual personal decision that
players need to make he's decided to not
have an agent and when you make that
decision yes you are going to save the
one two or three percent is his mom
still representing him well yeah but you
know here's the problem there's really
no one who's engaging with the ravens
the ravens were ready to sign him last
year but no one from lamar's camp would
engage them in real meaningful
negotiations aimed at getting a contract
done and if anything you could argue his
injuries last year and his overall
performance last year may have may have
damaged his leverage and now they have a
guy in tyler huntley
that he's not lamar jackson but
he can run the same offense
and dollar for dollar for what it would
take to keep huntley around versus what
it's going to take to make jackson happy
once they find out what that is
that that's the reality and and when
josh allen did his deal dan
same draft class 43 million a year when
i saw the details of that deal because i
knew when i saw the initial report once
i see the details
i'm going to know
do the ravens
want to do this same deal with jackson
or does jackson want this deal as soon
as i read it and understood the details
this is a deal jackson should want so
all he had to do was go into eric decos
to the gm of the team and say let's take
the josh allen contract let's scratch
out buffalo bills and put in ravens
scratch out josh allen put in lamar
jackson let's just do that that's what
they should have done and it would have
been in both sides interest because it's
awkward for the ravens to not have an
agent to talk to because when there
isn't an agent you know sometimes you
gotta speak some hard truths in the
negotiation they can't do that with
lamar jackson they risk alienating him
if they tell him why you know they don't
want to pay him 50 million a year so
it's a tough spot for everyone but i
feel bad for jackson because he should
have his deal by now and because he's
decided to go without an agent he
doesn't have it
i didn't have an agent for a long time
and when you sit down with
i sat down with dick ebersol so here's
one of the legendary
sports figures in this business
and he couldn't do it
he said i i
i can't i can't have these converse i've
never done this where i had the
conversation about a contract with the
person not an agent and he passed it off
to you know the guy underneath him who
had no problem in telling me some of my
limitations there
but he couldn't do it he just said no
it's too awkward there and i just
remember walking out of his office and
my wife said how did it go i said
he couldn't have a conversation with me
about it he'd never done something like
that uh the nfl offseason the overtime
rule the competition committee
to me it feels like this is there's a
logical end game here and it's just both
teams get a chance to have the ball and
maybe it's just in the postseason like i
don't know
how you modify this um
you know how do you tweak it but it
feels like hey you score a touchdown we
still get a chance and then everybody's
going to be happy here
is it as simple as that mike
it really is dan and in the days up to
the super bowl when we had the five-hour
pregame show and i had to go shake the
trees to try to have something to
actually you know talk about when they
put the camera on me and said go one of
the things i tried to delve into was
what's going to happen with postseason
over time and it's
as of three weeks ago it's more of a
matter of which way is the wind blowing
but it was blowing in this direction
guaranteed possession for each team no
gimmicks
nothing different than just playing
football but it would be in the
postseason only now the colts have
proposed a change that would apply
postseason in regular season i don't
think they're going to touch regular
season they don't want to extend the
games in the regular season in fact i'd
be fine with them going back to straight
sudden death in the regular season just
to get the game over with and let the
teams get ready for the next week and i
won't be surprised if that happens at
some point but for the postseason you
got to guarantee a possession to each
team you can't have these results not
with the rules so skewed toward offense
the just play defense argument doesn't
work in 2022 it may have worked in 1982
it doesn't work now because the rules
are too conducive and when you get to
the postseason you've got the best
quarterbacks they're more likely to
drive down the length of the field and
score a touchdown and and walk off the
winner i i think that it's going to end
up being a guaranteed possession and a
great strategic decision to be made
by the team that matches
you're down seven you score
do you go for two and the win or the
loss
or do you go for one and then kick off
knowing it's now sudden death he's mike
florio pro football talk live co-host
and his new book is called play makers
guaranteed to upset everybody in the nfl
it comes out march 15th can be purchased
online wherever books are sold
you had the sean payton tom brady story
on pro football talk
and the dolphins were interested in
coupling these two guys when did this
story emerge like how close was this to
fruition
well i first heard about it even
before sean payton resigned from the
saints and it's something that's been
lingering and building and we got to a
point last week where we thought there
was enough there to report responsibly
not to be confused with my usual
irresponsible reports that the dolphins
were indeed planning to make a run at a
package deal of peyton and brady and the
flores lawsuit
killed it now
i don't know
who decided to pull the plug it's very
easy to say the dolphins realized we
can't do this now we can't do this this
you know wink nod set everything up
ahead of time get sean payton get tom
brady we can't do that
given the content and the allegations
and the gravity of the brian flores
lawsuit it's also possible the league
said you can't do that
and you know i've kind of heard rumors
along those lines but can't substantiate
that the league intervened and said to
the dolphins you can't do it and dan one
thing that fascinates me and i i'm
trying to find out the answer to this
question
how much of the brian flores lawsuit for
example the allegation in there that he
was pressured by stephen ross the owner
of the team to meet with a prominent
quarterback in violation of the rules
and everybody knows it was tom brady
back in 2020
how much of the lawsuit
was aimed at putting the kibosh
on the peyton brady coupling in miami
if flores knew it was coming if he'd
caught wind of it
did his lawsuit in part was it written
in part drafted in part timed in part to
keep the dolphins from doing it that's
something i'm trying to find out but
that's fascinating if flores just
decided you know what screw these guys
they they they violated my rights they
fired me when i should have continued to
be there they tried to get me to do
things that they shouldn't have expected
me to do and they got mad at me because
of it
they got this grand plan for 2022 this
lawsuit is going to keep that plan from
coming to fruition it'd be fascinating
if that was part of why flores said what
he said and did what he did when he did
it
you're going oliver stone there on me
listen it's all hey we know this league
well enough to know there's always
something going on behind the curtain
that's why we love it but you've been on
this story before anybody and that is
tom brady to the 49ers
and that was it feels like it's been a
at least a year maybe a couple of years
where you've toyed with it or thrown it
out there or rumor innuendo
can you still see tom brady playing
again and if so is it for the 49ers oh
absolutely and i got to give sims credit
he's the one that first brought that to
fruition a couple of years ago that
brady wanted to play for the 49ers when
he was a free agent after leaving the
patriots or while he was in the process
of doing so and the 49ers said no thank
you
okay good luck good luck with jimmy
garoppolo and i think the 49ers would
would admit that
they'd probably have a super bowl trophy
or two if they had gone with tom brady
instead of jimmy g but i think that tom
brady especially after this
sean payton miami dolphins tom brady
thing
i don't think he's retired dan i think
he's retired from the buccaneers that's
what i think the retirement was i think
he's trying to find a graceful exit from
tampa bay
he got his super bowl win
last year they took a step back
and now i think he is eyeing a place
where he walks through the door with the
deck stacked in his favor and what place
other than san francisco
give trey lance another season to sit
you walk into a team that's super bowl
ready that that is dangerous defensively
that has great weapons offensively you
got a quarterback who can make big
throws in big spots the 49ers become a
shortlist super bowl favorite if tom
brady ends up there the question is how
much of a fight will the buccaneers put
up if he decides in june or july that he
wants to leave and i would say they owe
it to him to give him what he wants he
brought a super bowl trophy to a team
that had no business being in the super
bowl and he filled the stadium last year
i think they should work with him and
give him what he wants if that's what he
wants to do but i think he's coming back
i just think he's trying to find a way
out of tampa are you willing to bet on
that
how much like a pie to the face
oh a pie to the face i mean part of the
face is nothing it depends i mean unless
it's like you know an acid pie no no no
normal pie pie of your choice anybody
want to take florio up on a pie to the
face paulie paulie will say that brady
does not uh not come back just the
niners were talking right just the
niners i'll do it okay so pie to the
face florio wait week one niners if he's
on
the niners who takes a pie to the face
paulie does paul paulie does and if he's
not on the niners then i take the part
of it yes
okay you come on the show and maybe your
wife can administer or uh chris sims
could administer a pie to the face yeah
it may have to be a virtual part of the
face but i'll tell you my wife would
very much enjoy the assignment yes he's
slamming a pine to my face yes i feel
like week one is a very important part
of this bet
why because couldn't you see tom brady
maybe like somewhere later in the season
joining the 49ers no i i you know
nothing brady does is
you know by accident like everything is
structured everything is planned out i
don't think he's going to go you know
maybe i'll join them week six i think if
he's planning then he's planning now and
he would be there he would want to be
there week one last thing you want to do
is all of a sudden trey lance plays well
and then you get brady and you're like
why did we get brady trey lance is is
here
pie to the face i like that oh
i got to ask you because everybody has
breathlessly been talking about this
that aaron rodgers wasn't in the london
promo for the packers in the abbey road
picture there uh where do you stand on
this mike
i think if you take the original 12-inch
vinyl abbey road and put it on track
three of side one and run it backwards
it says aaron rodgers is staying in
green bay
they had no idea how prescient they were
oh my god
i we got to be finding out here soon
doesn't it feel like today with mcafee
and he announces well
i think he's staying look when the news
comes out that they're working on a
contract why are you working on a
contract if you're not staying and it's
smart for him to work out the contract
before he gives him an answer because
he's got leverage if he says i'm coming
back now let's work out a contract
they've there's no leverage left to be
had and it's like you know this they
this report that he's once 50 million
dollars a year
to me is not surprising like you've
talked about if i'm the packers i just
say
i'm going to call your bluff here's two
years 100 million dollars guaranteed
that's it
ball game
and there's no owner in green bay that's
siphoning off millions to you know go
buy a super yacht they can invest every
penny they make back in the team and
they've raised like 70 million through
their non-stock stock sale they can do
this easily i think he's going to stay
dan where else is he going to go and
have a team around him like what he has
in green bay he's not going to walk in
somewhere else and be a super bowl
winner his best chance is to stay in a
division where the bears have a new gm
and coach the vikings have a new gm and
coach the lions are in year two of their
latest reboot the schedule is favorable
this year they could be the number one
seed again the question is can they
finish the job and get to the super bowl
great to talk to you as always and uh
good luck with the book thanks dan
that's mike florio pro football talk and
the book is called playmakers it's out
march 15th